so i'm so curious like okay so you got
into the cosplay scene like i guess late
2000s what was the convention experience
like back then because you know
now we have a lot of boundaries that are
set with our convention you know like
you know cosplay is not consent and
everything like that what was your
experience
let's start with the question is your
first convention was what year oh so
like yes that was like the first time
that i went as like uh just on my own
was 2009 right that was very like
overwhelming because i was only 19 then
and i was like it was i was there with
my friend i didn't have my parents or
anything so it was this very like
oh my gosh i'm dressed as sexy pikachu
look at all these people taking my photo
oh my god this is pretty intense but i
guess i'm just gonna smile you know but
uh it it uh that was that and then i
would go only to san diego comic con
every year uh until like 2011 i think it
was okay yeah and then i remember my
first ever guest convention was anime
revolution in vancouver which is an
amazing convention and i love everybody
that runs that con um
i highly recommend oh my god okay okay
so good i love canadians
so delicious
no because like because were you around
during like the glomping era or like the
the yowie
i think i just missed that but i
remember i think that was like mid-2000s
right i remember seeing yowie paddles
and being like yeah
and then i remember like a good idea you
missed that yeah and then like the the
caramel dancing glomping
phase
you know like i i think i think i dodged
all that i dodged all the glomps and
everything i would see it in the halls
though with the little homestuck kids
and i'd be like what are you guys doing
you didn't miss like the free hugs era
did you free hugs
did that ever die no it still happened
no it's still happening it's just not
many people go up to them anymore yeah
yeah i think uh i don't know i i i think
i was really lucky in my convention
experience where um i i learned really
early on that i need to have people
around me to like yeah yeah and then i i
skirted around and i was kind of like
okay let's just we're gonna keep you
know yeah yeah yeah i think i think that
is pretty lucky because i i hear a lot
of stories back there where people did
not know boundaries at all especially
when it came to like cosplayers you know
yeah i've been i've been
yeah yeah well i mean that's what
started the whole like cosplay is not
consent movement yeah people are sad
that you even need to have that right
yeah yeah you think it's common
knowledge but well because what people
people will do is they'll come right up
to you and they'll look at your costume
and they'll start touching your costume
and that's that's something that is like
okay what are you ready
but um but that's why like glomping was
such a nightmare when you think about it
because it's like you're literally in a
hall full of people you've never met
before yeah probably not very hygienic
either yeah and then just suddenly you
could just get
hug tackled from behind yeah and there's
nothing you could do about it what i
want to know is how it became a trend in
the first place it's it's it happens in
anime all the time do you remember like
like people would like come home and
like they'd like like in love hina there
was that one character that would always
like dive bomb everybody and like and
yeah they would always get [ __ ]
punched right
that was what happened in anime yeah
because it's like you know it's like one
of the only times where anime fans feel
like they can kind of let loose yeah
yeah you get like a little bit carried
away yeah definitely yeah yeah you know
and it's it's it's sad
there was a time where um we were we're
at a convention and uh there was a guy
and he was like filming my bum and uh
ryan just came straight up i love ryan
so much oh my god i've got scary dog
privileges with ryan
he's like so scary but he's the sweetest
guy but he came right up to the guy and
he was like you can't do this right now
and he was like why not why not we're
not at a convention i can do what i want
he goes we want to take we got to take
you got to leave like calling like
security ryan is like the best guardian
angel you could have had
like he is
he saved me so many times um but yeah so
then the guy was like no no no and then
we had our other friend come over and he
was like nah you're out and then then
they he actually got kicked out which is
really great
right
yeah yeah because because like i think
back then just being at an anime
convention it felt like there was
because anime was like so underground it
was so rare to meet someone else who
also like watched anime let alone like
an entire room full of people who
watched anime so it kind of felt like oh
i guess all social boundaries are like
out the window now right we're all
friends because we like the same thing
yeah yeah we're we're all animated we're
all friends yeah yeah so we're all dtf
right
we're all like anime it's like no we're
not dta down to friend down to france
yeah
this is worse than the two wolves being
changed yeah not like my two wolves i i
think you've overdone it
twice we need a new one
all right i'll bring i'll bring another
one
yeah is there anything you miss about
the old school convention scene
oh probably just how much smaller it was
yeah let's be honest and then it sounds
i know that sounds a little bit like i
don't remember anyway but it's like no
but it's true like the smaller
conventions i've always had a better
experience at yeah just because it's
like more like especially when you're
like within the crowd you just feel like
you're actually being involved in the
entire scene the issue with a lot of the
really big ones is that it feels
extremely corporate
like a lot of the time
absolutely san diego comic-con's become
like that right like it shifts away from
showing off actually cool [ __ ] people
are interested in yeah into hey
we're a company we want to have a spot
in this thing to show off author yeah
it's basically just turned into e3 like
yeah yeah i mean but it's like let me
show you this cool thing oh yeah and by
the way there are some cosplays here
yeah yeah i mean it happens right
because i guess if the con gets big they
come wants more money and then yeah the
evidence of business right damn you
capitalism but you know there are a lot
of cons that are like we're just not
going to go above this size we're not
going to sell any more tickets yeah this
is what it is
yeah there's a bunch of those in the uk
as well it's pretty much all of them in
the uk i don't i can't think of a single
except mcn i don't really count mcm all
right
anime conspiracy mcm's like a comic con
so it's a bit of everything but in terms
of anime cons in the uk the biggest it
gets is about like
a thousand people yeah and the tickets
all sell out like the first day yeah
yeah it's very hard yeah there's this
one convention that i've been dying to
go to and it's in i think it's in poland
and it's called photocon and it's you
have to like sign up beforehand to get
to it you have to be like approved and
everything and it's in this gorgeous
little town in poland and they have
access to all the different like
churches and like ruins and like fields
and stuff and you literally go there as
a cosplayer with your photographer and
just take photos for the weekend right
and it's just this like magical like
utopia of like cosplay and photographer
and i want to go so bad that sounds sick
yeah that would just be cool to like
just use as an excuse to go around cool
places in poland as well exactly even if
you're not a cosplayer just be like yeah
i just want some nice photos of the
church exactly that's why i want to go
to a hawaiicon so i can like explore
hawaii
oh my gosh that's i think that's the
thing is that like personally for me i'm
just like gonna use conventions as an
excuse to go travel yes that's what we
did yeah yeah we did that from like 2012
to 2019. yeah yeah it was amazing so
like in in like your most busy period
how many conventions would you hit up or
like your job
you were going to a lot i remember yeah
so many we were like there was one year
we did like 30
or something and it was just like
were they all in america were they all
over you ever host
that's more than half the year yeah yeah
it was pretty it was pretty nuts yeah
that's like that's like three
almost yeah two three a month 25 30.
yeah it was a lot and then there was
like some where cause i remember we went
to san diego comicon they went to like
um well they were australia and then
we would like bounce around depending on
like what it was you know like canada we
went to spain
oh
festival unicorn was in italy right it's
amazing if they ever invite you it's so
amazing it's literally in this town
called vinci which is where like
leonardo da vinci you like kind of grew
up and it's in tuscany and you get to go
to this like
oh oh it's amazing like the call i got
to wear my blood elf in this like tuscan
town and like the food is amazing who
doesn't like italian pizza
uh i think i think american pizza is
better than italian pizza
ryan
ryan agrees
i just think it's got a little more
sustenance to it it's got a more weight
too i think it's two different things
entirely i i would agree yeah but if for
me if you like have to make me choose
one i'd go for american style wrong
wrong
i'm not i'm not saying that like it is
unequivocally better in any sense i just
that's what i would go two different
things
there are two pizzas inside of you
i just like how american pizza [ __ ] you
up
you feel disgusting after like you feel
so full like an animal
yeah it's yeah
it's down it's dtf
from that scene from dodgeball where he
like shoves the pizza and he's attached
is that you yeah that's me yeah yeah
yeah all right
ryan's vegetarian so he's like he's like
[ __ ] whole caesar's cheese pizza
yeah cheese pizza's the best though yeah
like it always goes to the hardest yep
that's right except you have the [ __ ]
for the next like two days nice and
skinny
i'm not like toast i'm good
why are you getting the shits from a
pizza because it's so much cheese
lactose like you're literally [ __ ]
through a straw after a pizza
no no it's fine it's horrible that's
your japanese jeans giving you lactose
intolerance what
because these people don't know how to
eat pizza it's like 90 80 of uh people
are lactose intolerant